خمس جولات تفوضيه فاشله حتى اللحظه بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا ثلاثه منها في بيلاروسيا
وواحده افتراضيه والاخيره في اسطنبول
التركيه جميعها لم تنجح في التوصل الى
ميقات مشتركه طبعا بشان المسائل الخلافيه
ووضع نهايه للحرب فالشروط على تناقضها غير
قابله للنقاش بحسب الطرفين لكن رغم انسداد
افق المفاوضات واستبعاد تسجيل اي خرق
يتمسك الرئيس سان بوتن وزنسكي بيضروره
التفاوض وانهاء الحرب بطريقه دبلوماسيه
تعبيرهم سنبدا بالشروط التي وضعتها
اوكرانيا اولها توحيد الاراضي الاخرانيه
نتحدث هنا طبعا عن عوده المناطق الاربعه
شرقي البلاد الى جانب شبه جزيره القرم
التي ضمتها موسكو عام 2014
سحب القوات الروسيه ووقف العمليات
القتاليه واعاده الحدود بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا لسابق عهدها من ضمن المطالب مح
هتقوم مرتكبي جرائم الحرب من روسيا
والافراج عن كل السجناء وطبعا ضمان امن
الطاقه وايضا الغذاء موقفكيف وفق صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز بدا اكثر تشددا مع تضاعف
الاتهامات للجنود الروس بارتكاب جرائم حرب
واستمرار نجاح القوات الاوكرانيه في ميدان
المعركه وفق الصحيفه غير ان شروطها لم
تلقى اصداء ايجابيه لدى روسيا التي امتلات
شعبتها هي الاخرى بمطالب لم تستسغها كيف
واليكم تلك المطالب الروسيه
[موسيقى]